when you got started like a lot of us it
was tough in the beginning you were
doing like what talent shows in
Australia well I did it I did some yeah
as a contestant the first one I did I
was 9 and my mum and dad thought it'd be
a great idea for me to go on the show
called pot of gold it's a terrible name
as a terrible show and I'm I went on
it's like an Irish bar right that's why
you were fired you know you can go
tomorrow yeah so I went on the show when
I was 9 and and sang I don't even what I
sang some sort of country song right and
and this guy called Bernhard King who
was one of the judges was just brutal
absolutely brutal years old didn't
matter
you know it's Australia cut you down you
know and so I finished the song and I
standing there and he said yeah this is
how I remember like cuz it was a long
time ago and my mum and dad didn't have
a VCR any that sort of stuff but they
had the little cassette recorder and
they propped it up next to the TV so
they could record the sound of the TV
and they didn't only keep my performance
they kept this crucifying critique from
the judge as well so you still have I
haven't burned in my memory okay yeah so
he he said I desperately encouraged you
to escape the mediocrity get out of
country and Weston and get into some
real music is that that's how he opened
I thought that's a good a good opening
right I'm just standing there going like
I didn't know what to make of it sure
and um he said otherwise you'll end up
sounding like Dolly Parton and
absolutely useless and he said he said
kindly learn to sing in tune because
you're intrinsically a good musician and
I remember something then he gave me at
four or something and I know I remember
senator mom and dad what is
intrinsically mean
nothing said it means that you can't you
know in in in inside you're you're good
and I got oh that's fantastic what a
great so you thought intrinsically was
you didn't hear the rest you just heard
intrinsic went with something that was
slightly good you know what would be
nice I don't know if this guy's still
alive but you're a superstar and he's
not alive anymore and I dad let's go
kick his grave then that's the meanest
thing I've ever seen
probably not now I've said worse you're
right
you